gen Z is number one search engine is
Tick Tock oh yes so Tick Tock SEO is a
real thing what are some of these new
updates so it used to be where you could
only have 300 uh characters in your
descriptions now it's 2200 but it's not
about you creating these very long
descriptions but it's more so about you
being very intentional about your
keywords for example let's just say
you're teaching about creating a YouTube
short well what Tick Tock wants you to
do now is they want you to be very
intentional about your SEO keywords you
would say how to create a video on
YouTube shorts now like you're going to
see above your video a little search box
you will see how you did a good job with
SEO because it will say how to create a
YouTube short up top and that lets you
know that your video is trending in that
particular category when someone goes to
search for how to create a YouTube short